[Music]
hello and welcome to the week in 60
minutes with me katie balls your host
for this week
the country has been hit by wide-ranging
train strikes this week which have made
things relatively difficult for many
commuters and even for some politicians
will rail workers get what they want
i'll be joined for a political update by
our team james forsyth and isabel
hardman
meanwhile we're entering the fourth
month of the russian invasion of ukraine
though western sanctions have been
extensive
they have had a mixed result as kate
andrews looks on the cover she'll be
here to discuss this with me alongside
the economist julian jessup
one way that the west could help ukraine
is by providing more arms that's the
case that lana morinettes makes in this
week's issue
she was a journalist in ukraine
but is now a refugee in london and an
internet spectator
she'll join the show shortly
the pandemic hasn't just had financial
repercussions it has also opened up more
doors for medical advancement
i'll be joined by the science journalist
matt ridley and the oncologist carol
sakura to discuss whether there is a
vaccine around the corner when it comes
to cancer
and finally as we look ahead to a summer
travel disruption with airlines and
airports failing to keep up with demand
jonathan miller champions an unlikely
solution
reiner
he'll be on the show shortly to tell us
why he believes this budget airline is
the best and most reliable option
a spectator subscription is now better
value than ever
as a new subscriber joining today you'll
pay just one pound a week for unlimited
online and app access in your first year
if you want the magazine delivered to
your door on top of that is only one
pound a week extra and your first month
is free and without obligation to
subscribe today go to spectator dot co
dot uk forward slash tv offer and why
not also subscribe to our youtube
channel click the red subscribe button
at the bottom of the video and tap the
bell icon to make sure you never miss an
episode
it's been a chaotic week so far as rail
workers have gone on strike but what are
the political repercussions
i'm joined now by our political editor
james forsythe and assistant editor
israel hardman
isabelle james thank you for joining
spectator tv today
now the big political story of the week
has been strikes the government did not
manage to prevent them from happening
but yet there are some in downing street
you don't think it's all so bad for them
james who's currently feeling the
political heat when it comes to the
strikes
so all the strikes that we might have
this summer i think this rail strike is
the easiest one for government to deal
with politically rail work is relatively
well paid and it's the first bit of
disruption this summer and so the public
kind of tolerance for it is fairly high
uh i think the challenge for the
government comes if these strikes keep
on happening keep on going uh and people
and voters move to well why can't you
sort it out one way or the other and the
government has a vulnerability here
because in its manifesto and in its
first queen speech in 2019 it promised
that it would legislate for minimum
service
levels so that you couldn't have a rail
strike that that ground the entire
network to pretty much to a halt as has
happened twice this week and
that hasn't happened and that that is a
vulnerability for the government for the
labor that the issue is where do they
stand on the strikes so kierstrama said
he didn't want any front ventures out on
picket lines but inevitably there were
some prom ventures out on picket lines
so so what is his position on the strike
and he's you know what disciplinary
action is he going to take against those
front ventures who disobeyed him
and is about how is kirstama dealing
with that do you think his authority is
being weakened by the fact some have not
really paid attention to what he said on
this
i think it has and i think the approach
that they're taking
which is to wait until the strikes are
over
and then discipline um those who defied
that instruction not to join picket
lines it i mean it does make sense
because you don't want this sort of drip
drip of labor sackings and rails and
stuff but but it's also partly a way of
just kicking the can down the road for a
little bit longer um because this is
going to be really difficult for him to
do
and uh even though still a relatively
small number of labour mps who went on
to picket lines 25 i think it was um
the feeling in the wider party
is still one of quite a lot of
discomfort actually that he hasn't
um been more supportive
of these strikers and uh it was very
interesting i was talking to some of
those around the labour leader who i was
really surprised were very confident
actually about uh their position uh
opposing the strikes and um
uh banning people from the picket lines
uh they said that uh there were um
there were focus groups that the party
held last week
where they tested the uh the
conservative message which is these are
labour's strikes and you know we've all
seen those going out on the conservative
campaign emails um we've seen them in in
graphics that the conservatives have
been putting out everywhere
and so on um but i'm told that in these
internal focus groups this message was
largely laughed at by the voters who
felt it actually tapped into
the wider sense that boris johnson just
is always trying to blame someone else
and actually you know the labour party
aren't in power so how are these their
strikes even if some of their members do
support it that's why kirstama was quite
happy to talk about the strikes at prime
minister's questions this week
but i don't think it's a happy labour
party and and this is one of his
problems is that he
doesn't have the
um well
as angela rainer put it the sort of you
know he doesn't give it as much welly as
uh other potential leaders might do and
so there's not that sort of groundswell
of excitement about kia stammer that
makes uh other people in the party say
no no you know we've got to hold this
line because we want to win and we'll
just do what he says um actually
there's a lot of worries about him much
more widely than just his position on on
strikes now it's going to get much
harder for him and for the government um
as we head into
um the the summer and the autumn uh the
conservatives are obviously heading for
a summer of discontent which is one of
the things that he's hoping to exploit
uh but when does he say that labour
members labour mps can join picket lines
and when does he say that they can't
does he end up sort of favoring certain
workers over others for instance uh the
government's going to really struggle um
if we get industrial action
from nurses or teachers but it's also
going to be difficult for um for the
labour party as well james let's talk
about the government's issues that
isabelle just
referred to particularly on public
sector pay now we expect there to be
more strike action in different
industries
and the government line and the land
from boris johnson is there could be pay
increases but don't expect them to be in
line with inflation
which we expect to hit double digits and
because this would be the wrong move and
would make the problem worse
how tricky is that going to be to hold
i think it is going to be difficult to
hold because public sector workers
didn't get particularly big pay rises in
uh post-2010 it's one of the ways in
which the the the coalition government
tried to kind of keep a lid on the
public finances and you've already seen
the national education union saying that
they want an inflation or above
inflation pay rise for their members now
i don't mean they're going to get that
but you know the the uh a teacher's
strike would be much more difficult and
much more disruptive for the government
to deal with than a rail strike and so
the question becomes
how do you
do this how do you find a way to avoid
uh
uh these big increases because i mean
also the fact is this that you know
a lot of private sector firms are
looking to see what the government does
and if the government says you can have
eight or nine percent i mean you'll see
more private sector firms feeling uh
that they should follow suit uh then
there's a worry but you you hear from
some secretaries of state but unless
they give relatively generous pay rises
to to to to the workers in their sector
that they will leave you know that care
home staff will go off to uh work in the
supermarket for example uh so i think
this is i think that you are you there
are there are going to be tensions over
this policy uh and
it is an interesting test of how
determined the government is to stick it
out
now israel we're speaking ahead of two
by elections and when those results come
through we'll have all the coverage on
coffee house and as we get it
but for now um speaking ahead of what
could be a storm for boris johnson and
the mood in the tory party you have a
situation where boris johnson is
actually going to be in rwanda and when
the results come through and it comes
after last week he at the last minute um
well
by the sense of those mps on the ground
at least
pulled out the northern research group
conference um to go to ukraine i think
he's been out the country for over a
week actually from today
so you have a situation where the prime
minister
is far away and i wondered do mps feel
as though boris johnson is neglecting
domestic duties or do they understand
that he has international business to be
getting on with
i i mean i think it's both
in a sense because they do like um
the relationship that boris johnson has
with president zielenski of ukraine
um they
by and large um
are very keen um for uh the government's
rwanda policy um to go ahead and
obviously that's not why he's in rwanda
he's in rwanda for the commonwealth
heads of government but um part of this
trip has been choreographed so that he
will have tea with prince charles where
he is expected if the topic is raised to
say he's very proud of
the rwanda policy um so
there's that this is also uh i think one
of the longest foreign trips that the
prime minister has taken in one go
and
i think to a certain extent conservative
mps feel he's quite remote even when
he's back here so i'm not sure that the
geographical distance is is necessarily
the issue now northern research group
mps were obviously very offended um by
his decision to choose the day of their
conference which they were very excited
about having him there for um to go to
ukraine i have to say that um some of
that excitement was partly because i
think some of them wanted to humiliate
him um in the question and answer
session that he was going to have to do
with the audience there so perhaps you
can understand why he decided to uh to
go somewhere
probably more peaceful um than uh than
the conservative party but um
but there is an issue with them feeling
as though they're not being listened to
which as we know is always an issue in
the conservative party even in the best
of times thank you isabelle thank you
james
now before we go ahead with the rest of
the program i just want to tell you
about the spectators innovator of the
year awards which celebrates
groundbreaking companies around the
country
if you're an entrepreneur please do
apply a spectator or code uk forward
slash innovator
the closing date is the 4th of july when
the russian invasion first began in
february many were shocked and impressed
by the west's extensive and decisive
sanctions
surely all this will crumple putin's
economy and by extension his authority
yet as we reach the fourth month of the
war that doesn't seem to be working out
as planned
in her cover article for the magazine
this week kate andrews takes a look at
the sanctions
and asks why it hasn't worked as well as
many hoped
she joins me now together with the
economist julian jessup who has written
for the spectator on where the russian
economy is hurting
thank you for joining us on spectator tv
kate and julian kate in this week's
magazine you look at putin's billions
and whether the sanctions by the west
and other countries are really working
can you give us a run-free to begin with
of what has been put on the table so far
so there have been a vast array of
sanctions uh coming from the west
targeted at russia from freezing the
accounts of notorious oligarchs to
freezing russian banks and companies out
of financial system the goal has
essentially been to push russia and its
economy uh to the outer limits of the
global economy and to keep them out of
as much as possible putin's central bank
assets of which they're about 600
billion dollars worth about a third of
those have have managed to been frozen
by by the international community
because they're foreign assets so
quite a lot has been done but what this
article really looks at is arguably one
of the most important sanctions that was
not brought in early and in many places
still hasn't been brought in and that
would be on russia's energy and without
bringing in serious sanctions on russian
energy what we've seen as this war has
caused energy prices to spike the cost
of oil the cost of gas all going up is
that putin has actually been raking it
in at the moment he's bringing in about
800 million dollars a day and about a
fourth of that is coming from germany
alone
and so when you put that into
perspective we can talk about economic
sanctions all we want but the west is
still very much funding putin's war
chest um it's difficult for him to spend
a lot of that money and and i think
that's one area where you can argue that
perhaps the sanctions are working but
but the point of this article is that it
really is a mixed picture and if the
goal was to completely
[ __ ] russia's economy and to deprive
putin of these of funds for his for his
war chest arguably we have not been all
that successful
julian do you think the sanctions could
be backfiring
well first of all i think i agree with
almost everything that caters has just
said um i would say though that economic
sanctions i think always going to play
sort of second fiddle to the the more
important issue which is making sure
that russia loses the war in ukraine
itself and you know so far the evidence
is that militarily it's been a disaster
for russia i think that's probably the
single most important thing at the
moment um as far as the economic
sanctions are concerned i agree that
they've probably backfired in the in the
short term um in the sense that they've
actually raised the the price of the key
commodities that russia is selling
they've still been able to find good
markets outside uh europe and the rest
of the west
but i think in the longer term they will
be far more effective and i think that
that is the bigger issue for for russia
um yes they've been able to sell some
more energy in other commodities at
higher prices now but it's pretty clear
that the long-term tide is moving
against them you know europe will slowly
uh diversify away from from russian oil
and gas and that's a big hit to the
economy uh on top of that you've got all
the if you like the softer stuff as well
so the you know the brain drain from
from russia the the cultural isolation
all those sorts of things uh they may
not have much immediate impact on the
the headline economic numbers but
they're undoubtedly painful
and the fact that so many people who
have supported putin more or less
explicitly over the last few years the
oligarchs have been hit hard as well i
think there'll be some sort of price for
to pay for that in the future
but in the meantime i think we have to
be realistic and ask what the
alternatives were i mean clearly no
sanctions against russia would not have
been acceptable at the other extreme a
complete ban on buying russian oil and
gas would have triggered an immediate
recession in the west so i think we had
to be realistic and
personally i think we probably got the
balance about right kate how realistic
is it for germany to reduce its energy
supply when it comes to russia obviously
there's pressure
from other leaders for
the germans to do this but it is easier
said than done
oh it's much easier said than done but i
think that's that that's one of the the
points of the piece which is that um the
west wants to pat itself on the back and
say look at this amazing work we're
doing we've taken every step we can to
be an ally of ukraine and the truth is
we haven't taken every step we can
because for all the reasons that that
julian just pointed out um you know
it is near impossible for for germany to
overnight decide that it's no longer
going to import russian gas not least
because other countries that are more
energy independent like the us have not
been especially helpful um you know
there's been murmurs that the u.s might
help supply energy to to countries like
germany but we haven't really seen that
come to fruition so um you know unless
you want to essentially damn your
society to the lights going out in a
recession overnight
it's not possible but you know that
phrase just keeps coming to my mind this
is the one thing we didn't want to have
happen and the fact that putin is
expected to bring in more income this
year in 2022 when he launched his
full-scale invasion than he did last
year was clearly not the point of these
sanctions and i think we we need a more
honest conversation around it i
completely agree with julian that in the
medium to long term this is going to be
extremely painful for russia and
actually in the short term their economy
is expected to contract by 10 this year
four percent next year whilst the growth
figures and the predictions for the west
don't look great they're nothing as bad
as that and putin is starting to take
some very dangerous decisions and he's
playing some very dangerous games by
threatening to cut off food exports from
ukraine's port in odessa threatening you
know starting to to play with how much
gas he's actually importing to europe
you know suggesting look i can turn off
the tops if i want to um the result if
if he gets very serious about either of
those things is that people will die
from uh from the cold and from
starvation these are really serious
games and and he's playing them because
of the sanctions he wants to see them
disappear they are hurting russia
there's no doubt about that um but he is
in in my opinion in the short term
a stronger position when it comes to
european energy in particular we have
found ourselves in a position in part
because of these sanctions in which
europe is more dependent on russian gas
than russia is for for european cash and
that income because he's had such a
windfall of profits in the first half of
this year
julian what options are there really for
these countries like germany in the west
when it comes to
things they could do which would
perhaps make these sanctions more
effective but also not uh you know
backfiring so much that suddenly this uh
big domestic backlash which he touched
on
well actually one thing to say first is
that even if russia is in some sense
winning the the sanctions war in the
short term it's very much a hollow
victory and if we take the the russian
ruble for example the currency um that
has strengthened to something like a
seven year high against the u.s dollar
which is quite remarkable um but that's
been at the cost of a combination of
significant capital controls uh in
russia itself and also a collapse in
domestic demand so yes russia is still
getting lots of money coming in from
selling commodities to the west and also
to countries like china and india
but at the same time it's not able to
import much from the west uh things that
it wants everything from military goods
to consumer goods and so on and so on so
that has propped up the balance of
payments which at face value looks
extremely healthy but underlying that
there are deep structural problems in
the in the russian economy that aren't
going to go away anytime soon um and i
think that's probably the the way that
countries like like germany should be
looking at this i mean um you know
ideally we in the uk or others in the us
might like germany to cut off imports of
energy from russia straight away but
i simply don't think that's realistic
there are lots of countries germany as
one italy is another who rely on russia
for maybe sort of 40 of their
energy particularly things like natural
gas and you can simply cannot
find alternative sources of energy that
quickly even with the the best will in
the world so i think we have to accept
that some countries like german and
italy are always going to be behind the
pack in terms of reducing their
dependency on on russian energy
but importantly they are signaling their
willingness to do so over the medium to
longer term
and that is having a big impact if you
look at for example you know russian
equity market that's still pretty
depressed because they're taking a
longer term view
of the viability of the russian economy
and the energy model in particular so
i wouldn't necessarily say that you know
germany and italy and the others need to
do more now
but they're absolutely right they should
be signaling their intention
uh to reduce their dependency on russian
energy over time and i think that's
where most the damage will come
and kate if we look at the illustration
of this week's spectator ultimately it's
putin surrounded by all this gold um but
even if he is uh you know raking in more
than he would be doing without the
sanctions when it comes to some of that
revenue
he is limited as julian mentioned what
he can actually spend it on and for
example with things such as um
the war and getting the right military
equipment it is gonna be quite tricky
for him to use that money in a way which
gets me exactly what he needs isn't it
yes and i think that's the flip side of
this where you can say that sanctions
are are having their effects uh it is
going to be increasingly difficult for
putin to import the the military
equipment he needs he's already finding
it very hard to get high-tech artillery
back into russia
and to julian's original point about you
know what we care about most ukraine
actually winning this war it's estimated
by uk figures that russia has already
lost a third of its ground force that is
sent into ukraine uh since it began this
war and and that includes a thousand
military vehicles that includes a
hundred planes that's going to be very
hard for him to
to get back into his military uh as well
you know he he's been known for years to
be working with russian businessman to
smuggle in microchips that are necessary
for military operations but patrols are
increasing it's getting harder to uh
circumvent uh you know us exports and
all the rest of it so you know this is
an area where in the medium term he is
definitely going to be feeling that pain
but because he does have access to so
much cash and he's using a lot of that
to stimulate artificially the russian
economy what it can buy him is time
and that is a very real concern us
especially as you know
i understand julian's point about you
know we need we need to be accepting
that germany can't wean itself off
russian gas overnight but i'm slightly
less generous uh to chancellor schultz
uh and and the government in germany
right now because
there's been a lot of talk of sending
ukraine weapons and more military
supplies and the ukrainians are saying
we haven't seen this yet
you certainly get a sense from germany
that that they would prefer for this to
end sooner rather than later and you
don't always get the sense um that that
they feel very strongly how that has to
end because this is causing so much
domestic pain um so as long as putin has
that time and he's able to artificially
stimulate his own economy i think that's
really bad news for ukraine winning this
war
and julian in terms of time frame kate's
touching obviously the pressure
has a current situation could give putin
time for these sanctions to be really
successful do you think they have to
stay in place for for a long time to
come
uh well yes i do i think the obvious
thing to do is to keep them in place as
long as putin is in power um i think
it's very hard to to see
the west re-engaging with russia as long
as putin is in power and presumably as
long as putin is in power russia will
hold on to whatever parts of ukraine
it's it's already taken um so i think
that we have to be in this for the for
the long haul as
um as kate said this is this is very
difficult to do i think it's probably
easier for us to do in in the uk and
possibly also in the us than it is for
for some european countries but i agree
with kate there's some worrying signs of
you know backsliding uh kate picked on
germany i'm gonna pick on france where
you know president macron seems to take
the view that we shouldn't you know do
much to upset putin um i hate to throw
around words like appeasement but it
does feel like that that you know some
countries are
too concerned about the potential uh
blowback on their own economies to
uh to take on somebody who is you know
clearly a murderous tyrant who's doing
lots of harm to his neighbors but also
even to his own country so
i think politically it's going to be
very difficult for all countries to stay
the course against
russia and continue with the sanctions
but frankly i think we have to we have
to until there's a regime change in
russia itself
and kate just finally um touching on
those points um we have a situation
where there's clearly concern among some
governments that there is backsliding
by other european leaders
um as as we've just had macron's idea
that putin should not be humiliated and
so forth so is this going to be a case
when it comes to sanctions of who blinks
first
yeah i think so um we have this dynamic
where we have a shrinking russian
economy and uh as julian said a
murderous tyrant who's sitting on cash
and time but is struggling to spend that
cash and at some point may start to run
out of time but you also have western
governments
that are looking at very stagnant
economic growth dealing with a cost of
living crisis across the west
in which people are getting very
frustrated and very angry we have an
inflation crisis on our hands too and
there is a question as to who can
sustain this longer um and you do hear
worrying um murmurs from from europe
that you know perhaps we're going to
have to come to some
faster solution
and what that actually means for ukraine
and for the sovereignty of ukraine and
for the safety of ukrainian people
doesn't always feel like it's at the
forefront of that discussion so you know
we always have to be realistic when we
consider this and um you know realistic
in in what kinds of negotiations might
happen realistic in time frames um but
if the west blinks first and and blinks
quickly and rapidly um you could
certainly find yourself in a situation
where putin isn't just gaming the
economic sanctions he actually also
manages to gain the military situation
between russia and ukraine
thank you kate thank you julian
so as as talk of certain leaders looking
at a backslide on their commitments when
it comes to sanctions what is the
situation like in ukraine why is it that
the ukrainians want to keep fighting to
discuss this i'm now joined by svetlana
morinets
she writes about what can be done to
help the ukrainian side in this week's
magazine she was a journalist based in
ukraine but she is now in the uk as a
refugee and she is also an intern at the
spectator
she writes about why ukrainians like her
family who are still there want to keep
fighting spitlana thank you for joining
us on spectator tv today
you write for the magazine this week
about why ukrainians plan to keep
fighting rather than go for a negotiated
settlement why is it important to you
oh it's a complicated question but
my family is there my friends are there
all the people that i know and i love
and they as me think that we should keep
fighting because
if not if we try to negotiate with putin
and give up some territories
eventually he will come back with a
stronger army so
we have been fighting this war for eight
years and
only now we've got a chance to win
because all the last eight years we were
fighting alone
with so few
weapons
and with means agreement they didn't
allow us
actually to
make the offense and make our
territories free
so right now
we can fight back and and i think we
should use this chance as fast as we can
until west still is still supporting us
and do you think ukrainians have reason
not to trust putin when it comes to any
negotiation
yes for sure because every time we were
trying to negotiate with him
we had to make concessions
and after that anyway he was breaking
them and
or attacking our army or how it happened
now
he made he
began a full-scale war
and
we saw that minsk agreements never
worked actually and they just helped to
like unofficially recognize crimea as
russian but
for ukraine anything worked and our
soldiers even couldn't shoot back
when russians were shelling us on the
bus
because
we couldn't break minsk agreements but
for putin and his army it was allowed i
think it is a little bit unfair
and do you worry about your father for
example you say he could be brought into
the army and would he have the right
equipment
yes
i'm
i'm terrified that they can call him up
to the army
and
i have to buy him
an equipment if they do it because there
is not enough equipment and even with
western support it is not enough
ukraine called up to the army already
one million of people and we don't have
enough
[Music]
special this protection that they use
that soldiers use
and mostly volunteers bring them and
people are donating money
and
i'm thinking that if they call my father
yes i will have to buy him
body armor by myself
it's one of the reasons why i'm
working in uk
because
that's
pretty expensive
and yet despite this you believe
ukrainians should keep fighting
what do you think would happen if
zelensky tried to agree to some peace
deal
it depends but mostly i think that
if he agrees to a peace deal that
is not good for ukraine for example
giving up some territories he might be
overthrown
as soon as democracy comes back
and he knows that
because
once ukrainians already
[Music]
kicked out
the president
back in 2013
when we had maidan revolution
and it was only because he
decided not to sign the association with
european union and instead to
[Music]
make agreements with russia and the same
now
after eight years of war and
45 000 people
dead
it it is before 24 of february now this
number is much bigger
we don't want any negotiations
the only option for us is when we throw
out russian army
from our borders
as it was before
we bring back all our territories and
after we negotiate as a winner
and
we make our points and our rules
and i think it is the only exact
acceptable thing for ukrainians because
otherwise
we will have to make concessions if we
are not in a good position for example
now now we can't negotiate because
the war
on the east right now is horrible and
as ukrainian army lacks weapons we
received only 10
of what we were asking for
we don't have good
chances right now for negotiating
and
that's why we have to wait
till
we get something for example as we
didn't let put into that cave we were in
a stronger position but right now as he
occupied almost whole logan's region
it's not a good thing for us for
negotiating
thank you swetlana for your time today
now if you want to hear more from
svetlana she is planning a daily ukraine
update in our lunchtime espresso
newsletter to sign up visit spectator
dot co dot uk forward slash expresso
remember if you enjoy spectator tv you
can subscribe to the magazine and to our
online content
join today and you'll pay just one pound
a week for unlimited online at access in
your first year if you want the magazine
delivered to your door on top of that is
only one pound a week extra
and your first month is free and without
obligation to subscribe today go to
spectator dot co dot uk forward slash tv
offer now for a spot of good news in the
near future we may have vaccines for
cancer scientists are currently
researching the potential for mrna
technology to enable jabs that will
allow the body to identify and attack
cancer cells
matt ridley author of how innovation
works writes about this development in
this week's issue and joins me now
together professor carol secora
oncologist and former chief of the
cancer programme at the world health
organization
matt you write in this week's magazine
that we could be on the verge of a
breakthrough when it comes to the war on
cancer as nixon called it can you talk
us through what's going on
well the most recent announcement came
from bioentech the german company that
developed a
vaccine against covid
and it showed promising results with an
experimental vaccine against
uh pancreatic cancer albeit very
premature
but it's part of
i think what looks like a
a step change in cancer treatment which
is greatly improved and personalized
immunotherapy where you get the body to
attack the cancer
do the job of attacking the cancer
itself and do so in increasingly
personalized way um and uh while i don't
think this is
a cure for cancer or vacuum for cancer
or the end of the war on cancer or
anything like that
i think it's right to be modestly
hopeful that things are going to improve
quite rapidly in terms of the ability to
survive cancer
carol when we're talking about this i
think it's talking about potential
vaccine being used in the fight against
cancer do you think there's uh calls for
cautious optimism here
i really do i think it's really a
spillover from covid days that mrna
vaccines were first used for covid there
are two
one made by bioen and one made by
moderna and they got the technology
right now it's much trickier to make a
vaccine for cancer than it is for a
virus and the reason for that it's
ourselves cancer cells that arise from
our own body and therefore look pretty
similar to the immune system so mrna
vaccines when you put
some cancer antigens some
proteins or some other molecule that is
expressed by the mrna
that mimics the cancer and drives the
immune system the t cells and maybe b
cells to the cancer could be effective i
mean immunotherapy has been around 100
years i did a phd in it a long time ago
over 40 years ago
and it's it's elusive but over the last
five years it's become much closer with
a group of drugs called checkpoint
inhibitors that have transformed the
treatment of melanoma renal cell kidney
cancer and a variety of other cancers
but this is something as as matt says
personal
you can actually take
genes from a person's cancer and divide
a vaccine to those specific abnormal
genes that have arisen and in that way
hopefully control it and as matt says a
small study
16 patients five of whom had rather
surprising
time after surgery before they developed
recurrence it's not curative yet but
it's the hint that this should work if
we get it right
and matt if uh eventually this did go
right um science would there be quite a
few complications that in terms of
rolling this out on a mass level for
some of the reasons we've just heard
yes because as carol says the the key
issue is the personalized nature of this
medication
you're going to develop a vaccine for
one patient
now you know it costs a lot to develop a
vaccine so if if you had to sort of
prove it safety and efficacy for one
patient it's obviously astronomically
expensive
but
uh nonetheless there are ways in which
you can think of it as a fairly
standardized procedure after all um
developing the lipid nanoparticle in
which the
vaccine is delivered
is a standard product um likewise the
ingredients of dna are standard products
so or rna in this case so there's every
reason to think that it it ought to be
possible to make these relatively
affordable and to know they're safe in
general
without having a very specific question
asked about the specific one that you're
doing for the specific patient
um all all the same
i suspect and i'd be very interested to
hear what carol's got to say about this
i suspect we're going to hit an
affordability crisis in
cancer um in the coming years where
yes there are very effective cures but
no they're not um cheap and
how we solve that
is going to get interesting
i think
you know
white powders in bottles are the
pharmaceutical dream that you have a
powder for every illness including
cancer and that's it you have pancreatic
cancer you take this powder you have
breast cancer you have another powder
very simple but the future isn't like
that it's going to be out personalizing
the medication as we can see here
specific series of antigens are
expressed on a cancer we have to get the
genes out for those antigens put them
into an rna molecule and then get that
to be expressed with the vector and
everything the lipid packaging and all
the rest of it and that's going to cost
and
but it can be automated as matt says a
lot of the
steps are sort of automated and they
were driven by covet and the urgency of
it the safety testing of rna has been
driven by copious i mean millions of
people have had these vaccines
whereas you know two years ago nobody
had had these even i've had them i don't
know what one of you had that but i
certainly had the fisa vaccine so uh
i think the future is about
understanding cancer at a molecular
level and then developing specific
therapies you know
when i do a clinic
mrs jones and mrs smith have exactly the
same type of cancer but the treatment is
almost the best treatment is probably
different but and i don't know how to
choose that on the whole
time will come when you will be able to
choose it not only that you will know
whether immunotherapy would be of value
so although it may be more costly you
won't waste drugs on people that aren't
going to respond so i think the future
is about personalization and
and i'm optimistic that
as matt says in his article
you know when i started as a doctor a
long time ago now
about 26 percent of people were cured of
cancer now
it's 49 nearly 50 in some environments
so i think things have changed and you
don't notice that change and i think
this sort of development personalized
treatment for cancer will make further
changes
my experience was was interesting and i
think quite typical of people i've
talked to which is that i tolerated the
oxford astrazeneca vaccines for my first
two doses extremely well
but the moderna booster
knocked me back for a few hours only but
gave me tremendous shivering chills as
if i had malaria for a few hours i went
to bed with seven layers on and couldn't
get warm now that's no big deal i was
over it as i say by dinner time but um
when i then read up on
the
rna vaccines i found that
that their problem had been getting the
body to not over react to the lipid
particle in which the vaccine comes and
that had taken them a number of years to
get right
um so how
how experimental are these vaccines
still because you hear a lot of people
particularly in the usa
saying
um vaccines are okay but i don't trust
these new rna vaccines
i personally think they're a wonderful
new invention and they're going to
transform
the speed of development of vaccines if
nothing else
um but i'm i'm interested in whether or
not there is a problem with side effects
that that needs to be tackled
i think the short-term side effects as
you've described that you had a fairly
common but as you say inconsequential
long-term perhaps more worrying with rna
vaccines can the rna insert itself in
some way in the host genome of normal
cells if it can then is there a cancer
risk 30 years down the line and that
that's the biggest worry not so much if
you're treating cancer with it because
the the the risk benefit is much greater
to do something but for vaccination
purposes for a disease for most people
is relatively minor such as covid
millions of people have been vaccinated
with rna vaccines
and will some of those have a higher
cancer incidence because of it so the do
mongers say perhaps
the more positive people say well it's a
risk but we have to learn to live with
it and i think
the treatment of preventing vaccinating
for infectious disease you really have
to have things that are really safe and
it was covered that drove the drive to
get
vaccines with rna quickly because it was
the only way you could get it quickly
the oxford was a a
a an alternative virus a totally
different product traditional
you know
what i've seen in my professional career
is
polio diphtheria tetanus all gone
because of the effective efficacy of
vaccines
and then you get cancer where we just
don't have effective treatment for
around half the patients so can we get
it out of this type of technology and
certainly that the benefits outweigh the
risks in a cancer patient so i think
here it's a good place to experiment
with different structures for vaccines
matt for the reasons we just heard do
you think we could see some vaccine
hesitancy if these were eventually
offered as widespread treatments of
course the pandemic is responsible for a
breakthrough but it did lead to some
actually you know really turning against
vaccines
well i i am concerned by the degree of
um anti-vax sentiment i come across
in the wake of the pandemic
um a lot of it completely species
um i don't know
who's responsible was it the fact that
there was an anti-vaxx movement before
this which has jumped on the bandwagon
or is it partly because
people feel they've been
rushed into
these vaccines
rather than you know as it were taken
taken with them and i i did uh you know
i urged government ministers early on in
the pandemic to to not say these are 100
safe you know to to to say to people of
course there are risks but they're worth
running and i think that that is the
right way to go
um
uh but it you know if you're if you have
a diagnosis of a cancer that is likely
to kill you and the doctor says i've got
an injection i can give you which is
likely to cure you i don't think many
people are going to hesitate
and carol i wonder picking up on
something you said earlier i just
wondered in layman's terms if you could
just give us a quick explanation as to
why it is that ultimately cancer is so
prevalent but has been so tricky to
overcome when it comes to medical
interventions compared with other
illnesses
so
it's partly because cancer is the enemy
within it's our own cells that have gone
wrong they're difficult to
if you know you can kill cancer cells in
a petri dish so easily you just pour
domestics on them or some disinfectant
they die but you can't do that in the
body they're just so similar and they're
like
terrorists they're rogue cells you can't
pick them up there's no way of
identifying them easily i think what's
likely to happen over the next decade
we're going to get better
understanding the cancer risk in people
and therefore tailoring screening
programs to cancer risk and therefore
using preventive strategies as well to
try and reduce the risk of getting
cancer cancer is very age-related and
people forget this the reason cancer is
going up in all western countries is
people are living longer so if you've
got more of your population over 60
you've got a much higher cancer
incidence if there's less of your
population over 60. and we're seeing the
shift now in poorer countries as well in
africa where because of the control of
infection there are more people
developing cancer so
they still have infection in some
countries hiv tuberculosis malaria and
dominating the population and now as we
get improvements in the treatment of
those diseases you end up with a much
higher cancer incidence as people live
longer so you can't deny living longer
is the aim of good medicine but it does
bring with it significant problems and
uh
i think
now it's just to say there's a tiny
silver lining which i write about in my
book which is that once you get past 90
cancer rates start dropping again and
past 100 they're surprisingly low i mean
centenarians very rarely suffer from
cancer and very rarely die of cancer
this seems to be carol correct me if i'm
wrong um because your metabolism is so
slow that the tumor just can't can't get
going or at least can't spread
and i think that's right and also the
fact that the cancer cells themselves
are the same age as you by definition
they've risen from cells the same age as
you so they've slowed down in old age
and it's true i mean if you take breast
cancer
you know breast cancer in ladies over 90
is a fairly benign disease most people
with breast cancer overnight don't die
of their disease it doesn't have a
chance to spread and it's easily
controlled by hormones
just tamoxifen very old-fashioned type
of hormone drug and it controls it and
yet in young women you see people you
know with very aggressive disease within
three months going from being completely
well to being seriously ill so i think
there's a lot of inexplicable factors in
cancer and again this means we do have
to personalize treatments not just by
age but also by molecular
characteristics of the cancer
and just finally carol i wondered
obviously different cancers uh have
different treatments and there are some
cancers such as pancreatic where the
survival rates are very stark and
worrying still do you think we could get
to a point in the in the next few
decades where um you know when you hear
that cancer diagnosis it stops being a
death sentence really um for many many
people
i think more likely it will get
gradually better from 25 percent to 50
in one professional lifetime is is
pretty good going uh the reason it's
unlikely to disappear completely is
evolution cancer cells evolution in
miniature darwin
came up with a concept natural selection
and mutation that's what cancer cells
are good at their mutate and those that
are more successful in outwitting the
drugs we give or the immune system
stimulation we give will outwit those
and start growing again so it's a
dynamic evolution we'll never be in a
world without cancer that was going to
be a slogan of the old imperial cancer
research fund when i was on the board it
was going living in a world without
cancer and it's just not achievable they
never used the slogan we said that was a
it's not possible to live in a world
without cancer but we can
decrease the serious consequences of
what can be a devastating disease
thank you carol thank you matt
and finally with airport disruption set
to continue for the rest of the summer
could ryanair be the answer
jonathan miller champions the budget
airline in this week's issue suggesting
that it is in fact far superior to
british airways and virgin atlantic
he joins me on the show now
jonathan thank you very much for joining
us on spectator tv this week um in this
week's magazine you say that ryanair is
horrible but it is still the best flight
service in europe can you explain why
well
you know i think grading airlines is a
relative matter
and i wouldn't say that i you know
anticipate
my flights on ryanair with the
enthusiasm that i recall for those old
the old days of going on to british
airways and in the days when women wore
hats to fly and men would wear ties and
it was a glamorous
a glamorous affair but nowadays when
travel is uh is is really kind of brutal
and you have to put up with these
overcrowded lounges and endless
formalities
um
and uh
it
it boils down to really something very
simple what does it cost and will your
plane actually take off and when you
come home will it actually
be there to pick you up and on those two
points
ryanair scores
without any question better than any of
its competitors and therefore uh
ryanair is really my first choice i have
i made the track the tragedy between uh
bezier and london very very frequently
and i've paid as little you won't
believe this as two euros
two euros to fly from bezier
to uh to stansted although i admit that
by the time i selected a seat the price
had gone to nine euros so that seems to
me a pretty good uh offering
and we're looking ahead to a summer
travel chaos i think some have already
experienced some of that chaos and but
what's really interesting in your piece
is how you uh look at the figures and
actually it appears that despite ryanair
son of suffering from low expectations
it ultimately appears to be doing a
better job at taking off and potentially
getting you there on time compared to
other aircraft carriers such as british
airways and easyjet
well certainly according to the the
metrics that i have seen ryanair is by
far the most
reliable airline in europe
and uh the least reliable is klm which
is the full-service
airline with fares to match
and the british airways and easyjets of
the world are all sort of mid-table
but we've read these horror stories of
british airways passengers stranded
without baggage for days and days and
days
and
people flying off on holiday and not
being able to get back but although
ryanair is is a favorite butterball
jokes
um i'd rather crash it
at heathrow than land at stansted the
reality is it offers a predictable
service at an agreeable price and you
have to say that one reason for that is
because of michael there uh
michael o'leary who
who uh who is quite ruthless
um in negotiating with his suppliers
indeed i would nominate him to run
british rail that might be a solution to
another problem
yes i wanted you to tell us a bit more
about michael o'leary because
well he's a he's a he's a disputatious
character he's a tough guy i mean he he
he's a he's a kind of genius for
publicity he once suggested that he
would charge his passengers to use the
the loo on the airplane he
i maybe this was a joke it's part of the
part of his
his uh
his his thing that you don't really know
what he's joking or he said why do we
why do we need seats on our planes why
don't we just let people hang on straps
he suggested at one point
why am i paying two pilots i don't need
to co-pilot if if if
if the captain gets sick why don't you
just get one of the flight attendants to
uh to land the plane so he's got a a
proven track record of being a
provocateur but it seems to work because
he's now got you know close to 500
or maybe a little more than 500 aircraft
in the air
and uh while he is unable to do much
about alleviating the misery of stansted
or luton
um
certainly uh he's there when you need
him
and you mentioned stan said reading your
piece i have to say when you talked
about those heathrow snobs i feel you
might be referring to to someone like me
in terms of my airport preference um so
although we're talking about cheap
flights if you do end up uh landing and
some are further out such as stanzard
luton don't you then have to price in
the fact it's going to cost you more to
get to where you need to go after well i
don't know i just uh did a
liverpool street to uh
stansted uh train journey
and uh
hey you get the benefit of seeing
beautiful essex but b i think it's
probably
half the price of the of the train from
paddington to heathrow um so
you know i clearly uh
you trade um
convenience you click you trade you know
those little immunity bags with the
silly eye shields that you get you know
on business class in british airways but
i you know for most people
including me
um the idea of paying
you know
10 euros or for a flight
compared to 10 times that price on on a
you know brand name airline is uh is an
overwhelming argument and you can spend
your time on the train reflecting on how
much money you're saving
and having to
and having to recently had booked quite
a few flights has been
a bit horrifying to see how much prices
are jumping so imagine lots of people
are thinking
where should we go instead so i wondered
jonathan if uh you know we imagine some
viewers are yet to experience the
delights of ryanair the sales pitch
you've given today has worked have you
got any top tips for how
they should prepare for that flight and
what they should or shouldn't do once on
it
well i think you know airports are
triggering for me i i you know it brings
out my inner misanthrope and i think
that's true with a lot of people so i
think you have to prepare by
just
having a rather zen attitude
um and uh
but there's
you know the horror of ryanair is
actually not really when you get on the
plane it's when you're waiting in that
departures area
at stansted with all of humanity
you know on the one hand one can applaud
uh michael o'leary who's democratized
air travel and opened up new horizons to
a whole group of people whose
previous experience of of travel might
have been limited to to a charibank for
a a weakened scum thorpe um
but the the corollary of that
is that these uh airports are really
kind of a horror story especially
on the london end although when you get
to a little you know he does tend to fly
to these secondary airports around
europe which are
often quite
quite tranquil in comparison
uh often they they are not particularly
close to the city they claim to be
when you fly on rhino to paris you end
up in a place called beauvais which
might as well be halfway to calais when
you fly to frankfurt and you're
practically in austria i exaggerate only
a little but if you can put up with that
you say uh you know this is how it is um
i i think it's perfectly acceptable i
think we should uh we should uh
honor michael o'leary and invite him to
in back to brit to britain to run
british rail maybe he can sort that out
and just finally gentlemen while we have
you here you're joining us from france
and this week we've had obviously uh the
results uh in the french elections
relating to how macron will govern and i
just wondered if you could give us an
update on what the mood is where you are
because it seems as though emmanuel
macron's had a bit of a disaster
well i think it has been a disaster as
i've as i've written for uh coffeehouse
spectator
blog
and as many of the other contributors of
the spectator in france it really is a a
kind of
political
fall to earth for jupiter who's um he's
met something of a waterloo he's got a
he's got a government that's a lame
lame-duck government that's not even a
month old
he's got a prime minister
elizabeth born who looks like having the
shortest tenure since
the only her only female predecessor
edith cressle who called
memorably english men
homosexuals and japanese ants
she's already offered to resign he
hasn't accepted it and that's because he
hasn't decided what to do next he's
having
talks in the elise but he hasn't
appeared in public he hasn't explained
or acknowledged that this result is
entirely the consequence of his own
arrogance i would say even
narcissism he was elected president
under this curious
system put it in place by general de
gaulle
uh
to uh to always steer the vote towards
the most moderate uh candidate um but
he's not not been liked here from the
very first
year of his presidency when he
triggered the uh the the zhilejon
movement by
raising fuel prices and lowering the
wealth tax
simultaneously um he's been a very
divisive figure
and uh quite a disagreeable
figure he
in some ways you think he's
uh
on the spectrum he he has a very hard
time relating
with ordinary voters and he seems to
spend a lot of time
avoiding them i think he made a huge
mistake by thinking that his re-election
was some kind of
endorsement of him when it's proven that
he's really
is unpopular has been unpopular and
looks like continuing to be unpopular by
by prancing around the world stage
declaring his ambitions to build this
this greater europe when my neighbors
are more interested in the price of
diesel and food
thank you jonathan thanks for joining us
today thank you so much katie bye
that's it for this week remember if you
enjoy what we do here at the spectator
you can subscribe to the magazine and to
our online content join today and you'll
pay just one pound a week for unlimited
online app access in your first year if
you want the magazine delivered to your
door on top of that it's only one pound
a week extra and your first month is
free and without obligation to subscribe
today go to spectated or coda uk forward
slash tv offer thanks again for watching
and do join us again next week
[Music]
you